- [Narrator] Meet Onyx, a five-year-old
eastern indigo snake.
(dramatic music)
At nine feet in length, eastern indigos
are considered to be the longest
native snakes in the United States.
Even though they lack a venomous bite,
they can fall victim to
overzealous rattlesnake hunters,
as they inhabit the same burrows.
Their beautiful, smooth-scaled skin
is a shade of bluish black.
Carnivorous, like all snakes, Onyx feeds
on any small animal she can overpower.
Onyx may hiss or rattle
her tail when alarmed,
but she'll hardly ever bite.
Like most snakes, humans
are their biggest threat,
as continued urbanization
has left them threatened
throughout parts of the United States.
This is the eastern indigo snake.